[Music]
let's bring some holiday cheer and
energy into this space real quick
i like christmas time mainly christmas
to me and you did you guys know that the
iconic home alone house
that right there marvin yeah that's the
silver tuna
it's available to rent on airbnb
i heard
it's not much either right it was like
20 bucks a night or something no no
20 bucks it's 25
up to four people will be able to stay
in the house for just 25 why so cheap
yeah is there no heating no insulation
no doors
tarantula is going to be laying eggs in
your mouth
because the scariest snow shoveler out
in the [ __ ] driveway upstairs [ __ ]
paint comes down
renting a room is it because it's
chicago i don't know the iconic home
from uh the 90s franchise home alone is
now available around airbnb holiday
rental platform announced that lucky
fans of the film will be able to rent
the original house so i think lucky fans
have to win it
just give it to them then if you're
gonna make it pay twenty five dollars a
night they use the word lucky i knew
that was a catch twenty-five dollars
yeah the address will be given once the
booking is complete for those lucky fans
and they'll also be able to set up booby
traps
and also be treated to a viewing of the
franchise's latest movie home sweet home
alone pizza and a candle lit dude
somebody want to watch that new one
though yeah who wants to watch it go
there can i no can i put a landmine in
front
can i do it
imagine that oh maybe the old dude
showing with the shovel coming i'm like
don't don't do it boom
that's supposed to be for marv no no no
no it's for the sticky bandits
the [ __ ] groundskeeper
no man
have you guys seen have you guys seen
the trailer for the new home alone movie
oh no it's on disney plus i don't know
if it it might be it sounds terrible but
it looks really bad
it looks like is there anyone from the
originals no no mccully everyone's old
as [ __ ] joe patch is not in it yeah
napoleon yeah macaulay also looks very
different i got to uh
act with the oldest brother in russian
doll
really
buzz
in the yeah in the convenience store
he's like he's complaining to me he's
actually a guy he's funny when we were
doing all the albums but he's like
complaining to me about his sick mom
he's one of the customers and i was like
whoa i was like this guy looks so
familiar and then when i made the
connection i was like oh my god
i was like and i was like don't freak
out don't breathe don't break
that was like the one because it was
like such a genuine you know nostalgic
reaction too he's like his girlfriend
that's good casting and i never wanted a
bb gun so bad for real a classic movie
man about any freaking toy in those
movies you just wanted after like the
[ __ ] talk boy yeah come on man talk
boy oh my god remember that [ __ ] i
remember when a friend had a talk boy it
was like the coolest thing on the block
and it was huge
those were huge things it was pretty big
it was just voice memos
it was voice memo i'd rather do
voicemails now i'm like [ __ ] this thing
i'm like
this is stupid
in a statement airbnb said this season
fans are said to have their dreams come
true with an overnight stay in the
original home alone house while the
mcallister is our way on their annual
trip all of them but the pet tarantula
four guests will get the opportunity to
relive their favorite scenes from the
holiday classic and let their inner
eight-year-olds run free for the evening
without the interruption of pesky and
true four guests though that house was
huge those wishing to book the state
will be able to do some do so from
december 7th so we can try to book it
and we'll try to book it we should one
of us can stay on the inside and the
other four of us have to sleep outside
like outside
out of us six two of us become the wet
bandits
the
you know
barbie did a special where that you were
able to rent through airbnb the malibu
dream house there's just such a real
house in real life in real life and it
was a legit malibu kind of like beach
house bunch of playboy bunnies around
what's up i don't know about that
maybe when you go hey yo but it was a
legit house
i never went
damn they didn't hook you up can you
never gone
unofficially
when ken shows up it's late night
yeah
let's go in the will they won't they
yeah you have to keep your distance
we're like you know we're like wwe
wrestlers we can't be seen in public
together
we don't want to we don't want to give
away the bad guys it's a good guy
storyline wait i don't remember their
house being so big dude it's huge
huge dude what what state is this i
thought it was like a hat like a smaller
brick house was it in colorado in the
movie where was it i think chicago i
think it's chicago maybe
wait did chicago
dress it like the sink yeah it looks
like yeah
why is it so much brighter looking the
furnace still there the photo
they removed it it's now a green energy
they lit it too nice solar panels no
it's no longer cold
no longer coal powder it's got to be
screen accurate man damn who owns this i
mean these guys must have paid off the
mortgage real well i got the [ __ ]
stats you guys wow wow no way just knock
it over with our car [ __ ] yeah oh buzz
that's your co-star there he is
is that buzz's girlfriend
that's it did he have a blogger around
he goes buzz's girlfriend
i love it that's on airbnb
the home sweet which is the one where
he's at trump tower the second that's
the second one oh it's actually hosted
by buzz
oh it is hosted by buzz entire
residential home hosted by buzz four
guests two bedrooms one and a half bath
entire home enhanced clean
like twenty five dollars a night booking
opens december yeah i gotta be honest
this looks like a catfish listing like
if you just said it does i'd be like oh
you sent me a catfish let's do it
beat the [ __ ] fish the catfish
the suburbs of chicago this is in
illinois
identity verified hosted by buzz joined
november 2021 it's not the same without
kevin
as the oldest of five it says in his
profile i was a little bit of an
instigator back in the day and perhaps
not perhaps not the most accommodating
general is he gonna be a character he's
still not accommodating he's only
allowing four people in like a
nine-bedroom house yeah that's crazy
generally seeking to torment my kids and
siblings but i've grown up and i'd be
happy to share my childhood home my
pizza even with you this holiday season
remember when they spilled the soda wait
look what you did you little jerk upset
he's a host
you little jerk oh that was good this is
good i love the uncle dude the
ball-headed
yeah that was a movie made for the movie
i always thought growing up that was a
real movie yeah oh yeah oh
oh they've just made it for hormone
right i thought it was like an old
school 50s movie yeah it just kills
everybody the guy's a scumbag i'm like
yo what is this movie i'm like this guy
just murders every dude in this movie
he's like you could go disgusting
one two
ten
i'm gonna change a filthy animals oh
good
great surprise now i just made the rest
of the movie yeah there's probably not
much it's just him killing everybody
they made that movie today would make a
lot of money
animals goes around killing people yeah
whoever goes to his office he just blows
that wasn't a movie it's like did you
not get me the highlighters that i
wanted
just repeatedly people keep coming in
that is the newest piece of information
i received today but that's not to ten
yeah well in the second one
uh was it the second one they go to
paris
new york the second one new york
family went to oh yeah they go to the
family first one that family is flying
to paris and they leave him at home
that's the premise of the first one the
second the second one they physically go
to new york and then he meets her up and
meets my parents go they their parents
go to florida right i don't remember yes
yes it's raining and [ __ ] yeah yeah so
one of the scenes uh
i think the paris one when they land in
in paris and the family's all waiting
for the phone call they're also watching
that the same movie the same movie but
then it's it's french french though wow
i do remember that yeah
john hughes man john yeah
he's the one that directed i don't know
no no i think no no christopher columbus
and um yeah that's what girl has
directed it barbie's ken is indian
oh tight dude
spoiler alert isn't there a home alone
three yeah yeah it's not even a car
there's even a floor isn't there look at
another bowl cut here they had like the
home video version you know that era
straight to v8 that's why they had like
1 million different earbuds
dude there's like 20 airbuds dude
there's so many like kickboxers
[Laughter]
they're an airbud the first two are
basketball and then eventually he
switches sports there's like a football
he's the air retriever
he's the yeah he's the retriever
oh
retriever wide retriever
what if he wasn't a basketball player
yeah he was basketball football but not
air but seven but he also played like
soccer she really called wide retriever
something like that it was a play on it
it was a play on it you think he ever
gotten to like that's awesome because he
could catch it and he was like you know
and then he'd always leave him out
that kid didn't deserve it he got into
like weightlifting like olympic
weightlifting or kickboxing and then
people got really scared because they
were like he's not a man or a woman he's
a dog and then like started that trend
like you can't compete that was the
first argument we need to test them yeah
every sport a golden retriever [ __ ]
crushing it all sport
mma yeah
[ __ ] even dance
dance competition you know he's popping
and [ __ ] he was like he was doing
players he's [ __ ] doing the
moonwalking [ __ ] what he can roll on the
ground he does a moonwalk with all four
feet
wow
[Music]